[Music]
so we are way to the date night and
melee turns to me she goes so I think
Donald Trump's gonna become the
president and I think our baby's name is
Dimitri and I was like Donald Trump's
not gonna win Ashton Kutcher proves just
how and no wife Mila Kunis's on Mondays
Ellen show from knowing the next
president to picking their newborn son's
name then two weeks later I got home
from work and for some reason the name
just stuck in my head and I was like I
think Dimitri's the name of the baby it
she was like I know right and I was like
yeah that's it and chubby give
everything Mila said is right he's up
what she's my wife so that's what it is
yeah right my bad the ranch star also
joked about how much their two-year-old
daughter Wyatt loves her five-month old
brother Wyatt thinks the baby's her baby
and at some point I'm gonna have to
explain her it's not really her baby
it's like Of Mice and Men she's like I
love you and hold you it's crazy with
maybe George and I'm like afraid she's
like Lenny I'm like she's going you're
gonna like squeeze the baby's head off
on him yeah oh my god he's like Kung Fu
Panda when she comes near cuz he's
afraid she's gonna kill him
[Music]